let's go to Smitty from Los Angeles
Smitty from Los Angeles California
welcome to the program welcome back I
think right you've been on
I have I have good morning David how are
you I'm doing well
great
um so uh uh Ben
um Shapiro has kind of been still in
some of the language that you use uh he
started using on his show
so I listened
kind of hear what he's saying which a
lot of times is just crap but what
language of mine has he stolen
he started using the phrase you use
where if all you have is a hammer then
everyone looks like a nail well I didn't
invent that to be clear
no but I haven't heard of anybody else
in podcast doing fair fair language he
he certainly I've been listening to him
for a while because I do like to get the
other perspective yeah and just share
what
things are trying to get away with
saying but um yeah so I just thought
that was where I thought I would report
that to you interesting
anyway uh I guess my question is today
um
with the book Banning in Florida and
that sort of thing
isn't that something that
teachers could actually Sue
um pseudosanthus over on first uh on
First Amendment grounds
yeah yeah you know I obviously I'm not a
legal expert my formal training is in
dentistry so I I'm a little bit out of
my
um comfort zone here but from what I
have read
it is arguable it doesn't mean you would
win but it could be argued that
if a state government says you can't use
these books or whatever the case may be
that you would have some kind of a free
speech case but you know these things
often come down to I don't want to call
them technicalities but they they come
down to very narrow aspects of the law
and definitions that exceed you know my
ability and it sounds like yours as well
since you're asking about it to
determine that as a layperson it sure
sounds like there could be a First
Amendment argument there
I mean that's what I thought I just
haven't heard anybody I would assume
that somebody would already
be taking him to court over that or
something
certain aspects of it but I haven't
heard that yet so I mean listen what I
would be more concerned with in a sense
although obviously if there's legal
remedies that they should be pursued is
that as I said earlier this week the
book Banning and idea Banning stuff is a
prominent characteristic of fascism and
that should very very much scare us
exactly yeah exactly that's what I'm
very worried about I'm just continuing
to see a lot of signs that
are are not very good I think we're in
for a long fight and we all need to be
diligent in doing everything we can to
contribute in ways we can to prevent
this from getting any deeper I mean I
would I was hoping that
the party would experience the
Republican Party would experience some
kind of
um
Spiritual Awakening but I'm not actually
that happen with them yeah the only
Spiritual Awakening they seem to be
having is that they they now are very
much in favor of Christian nationalism I
saw a new poll about that but that's a
depressing topic for a different day
Smitty
yeah so I have one thing I wanted to uh
see if I could just uh
um reach you real quick or something I
can tell you about so I had chat GPT
uh write a song about you you want to
hear the first verse okay yeah sure
he's a man with a mission speaking the
trick with Precision from politics to
pop culture it shows a decision he's the
one and only David packman's name and
when he speaks we all listen and the
truth isn't big I like it first one I
like it very much I would consider it a
success
all right well thank you very much sir
all right Smitty uh sir thank you with
tears in my eyes uh we say goodbye for
today but uh not forever not forever one
of our sponsors today is mosh whether
you're at the gym on the go between
meals mosh protein bars are the smart
snack to keep your body and brain fueled
there's six delicious flavors like
blueberry almond crunch peanut butter
chocolate Crunch cookie dough crunch
each mosh bar comes packed with 12 grams
of protein six grams of fiber but also
important nutrients like vitamin B
vitamin D
Omega-3s and only one gram of sugar and
160 calories I've tried tons of
different protein bars really you can't
beat the taste and the texture of mosh I
love these my favorite is the chocolate
Crunch simple satisfying now that I'm
back in the gym I'll snack on one of
these after workout mosh is also a
mission-driven company with a portion of
all proceeds donated to support women's
brain health research through the
women's Alzheimer's movement at
Cleveland Clinic mosh is giving my
audience 20 off plus free shipping on
your first six count trial pack go to
moshlife.com Pacman the link is down
below